[Musique]
qu'il est bon de ne rien faire et de
rêver en respirant le bonheur pur de
l'îlot z'enfants
désunir
casimir oui tu as pas te voilà enfin
qu'est-ce que ça arrive assez vous
facteurs excuse moi juste déranger non
non pas du tout vous avez un peu troublé
ma rêverie je respirais au jeu je tends
nuit non non je n'arrive jamais à mounir
moi même alors je ne vois pas comment
vous pourriez y arriver pour sûr ça
c'est bien ça c'est tu as du caractère
quasi mis un aa c'est bien ou c'est pas
bien le caractère et bien c'est bien
quand on a bon caractère et si mal quand
on a mauvais caractère
mais pour sûr tu as du caractère tu sais
ce que tu veux pour sûr wake ans a envie
de manger un bon globules bien je le
sais en enrôlant kazimierz eu un petit
peu sérieux hein j'ai une lettre pour
toi
c'est sur marne en admirateur kim écrit
pour me dire que je le fais beaucoup
rire peut-être bon casimir il faut que
je te laisse moi je ma tournée a
continué allez à bientôt à bientôt bonne
tournée au c'est une lettre demande de
mon cousin théodule oui oh là il me dit
qu'il est parti en voyage
on le pauvre où il faut que je fasse
quelque chose pour lui
j'ai une idée
françois françois roux et casimir
kustendil gens voudraient en ballon s'il
te plaît mais volontiers c'est pour toi
non non c'est pour envoyer à mon cousin
théodule qui est en voyage à
celle et c est magnifique la couleur est
très belle d'autre part la couleur n'a
pas d'importance le ballon non plus
d'ailleurs mais alors casimir tout comme
la chute
écoute je te lâche est dans le pays
alors que n'a pas besoin de poser
question rap bon c'est juste surmonté
cuisiner c'est combien
la france 50 d'un coup tu m as assure
maintenant la puce est bien que je n'ai
pas de poche comme d'habitude au fait tu
n'as pas vu le facteur ainsi il vient de
partir par la part la bombe et je vais
essayer de rattraper parce que j'attends
un catalogue il a dû oublier de le
porter d'accord
julie
puis julien casimir julie écoute je
voulais un ça va tu sais je n'ai plus
aucune dette effrayant 10 avril meilleur
tu est là mais la sni caramel au point
du chardon ou quatre épices et il sans
parler des clous vis boulga je n'ai plus
rien en ce moment même mais non je ne
veux pas quelque chose à manger
pardo bah oui oui c'est juste leur dû
les clés les dix minutes de la journée
pour je n'ai pas envie de manger faire
la chance non je voudrais une grosse
caisse tu veux jouer de la grosse caisse
dans l'orchestré de lille aux enfants
mais non je voudrais une grosse caisse
en bois et ben écoute ça tombe très bien
j'ai là justement la caisse de ma
dernière livraison de poupée qui
m'encombre la voilà
quelle est la plus ouverte que ce soit
le cas c'est en ouvrant le sac blanc
vient ça ne fait rien ça fera
parfaitement la faire qu'est ce que tu
veux en faire on raconte julie je te
débarrasses beauté vieille quesque alors
ne pose pas de questions je n'ai pas le
temps merci julie pour moi
nous sommes étaient jumeaux il faut que
je range ses poupées
m
[Musique]
quel changé c'est beaucoup de place mais
bon je vais leur mettre dans la caisse
mais que je suis bugs mais il a donné à
casimir
il faudrait quand même que je me décide
un jour à avoir un peu d'ordre vous ne
trouvez pas
c'est parfait il rentre juste dedans on
dirait que cette caisse a été faite
spécialement pour mon ballon mon
excellente amie d'aignan représentants
des glorieux casimir us mon brave mais
on estimait campagne en un mot comme en
cent membres à casimir je te dis bonjour
c'est parfait en largeur aussi ça va
très bien casimir je te fait l'honneur
de te présenter mes salutations il faut
que tu me rendre la politesse quoi
qu'est ce que c'est
je suis désolé d'avoir à me répéter
casimir et je te prie de m'en excuser
mais les circonstances me contraignent
j'attends vous attendez c'est une très
bonne occupation au maillot du snob
continuer mais vous attendez quoi rond
juste un
jour à je viens de te donner mes
civilités faut que tu me rendes mes
salutations un veau salutations mon bac
ce sera avec fait un salut c'est tout ah
ben on
dit que c'est mirren la discrétion n'est
pas un défaut qui l'habite mais
j'aimerais savoir ce que tu fais je suis
en train d'emballer un ballon gonflé
dans une caisse en bois
et lamballe un ballon
je n'y passe souvent par la bouffe des
êtres simples merveilleuse ce bowling
tous les ballons du monde voyage et donc
lui ce serait comme ta place on veut
retirer afin de méditer sur cette
époustouflante vision adieu casimir on
revoir monsieur 10 novembre
bon enfin il me reste plus qu'à mettre
le couvert tu l'as pas oui mais il n'y a
pas de couvercle on sait bien qu'ils
soient il me faudrait deux trois petites
planches
oh j'ai une idée
bon comment commencer la coupe 1 en long
en large pourquoi laurent travers
casimir rebelles et full méca chimiste
arkema mon dieu mais qu'est ce que tu
entraînes faire ça ne se voit pas mais
si ça ne se voit pas trop d'où tu veux
couper cet art toile est alors mon futur
n'a pas le droit françois connaîtra un
autre moyen de se procurer des planches
des pneus eh bien il faut aller chez les
autres sujets parfois tu répondes moche
mais j'appelle les autres secours e joly
monsieur dix neuf facteurs vite venus
ils étaient tous jeunes et qu'est-ce qui
a que la catastrophe avait besoin d'être
je suis là de quoi s'agit-il eh bien
casimir veut ni plus ni moins couper cet
arbre expliquez-lui vu mes amis pourquoi
il ne doit pas le faire moi pour une
fois chez pire nous enfin casimir il ne
faut pas virer à la q tu trouves pas que
c'est beau un ordre mais celui là c'est
le plus beau des innocents soient battus
qu'ils coupent s'attarde en gros de
coiffage ma sieste moisi miron
n'occupait pas un arbre en pleine force
de l'âge comme celui ci surtout quand
ils ne viennent pas la croissance d'un
autre petit arbre quand on coupe un
arbre c'est qu'il est malade alors oui
c'est très triste d'ailleurs on remplace
tout de suite par un jeune homme je ne
voulais pas lui faire beaucoup de mal je
voulais seulement coupé deux ou trois
petites planches mais tu sais casimir
une simple blessure peut tuer un arbre
je te les donnerait vote et planches moi
il y en a plein au bureau de poste un
bon beh oui ta caisse casimir on rentre
là moi que je prenne les mesures au
moins vous êtes gentil facteur venez
venez je vais vous la montrer
[Musique]
c'est un ballon qui est la nôtre dans
cette pièce ah oui le règlement des
postes ou l'interdît ah non non pas du
tout mais mais un petit paquet vendu
reviendrait moins cher plutôt que cette
caisse ah oui si j'envoyais le ballon
dégonflé mais moi je l'envoie gonflé
ouais c'est pour mon cousin qui théodule
qui n'ont dans un pays où il s'ennuie
beaucoup et tu crois que ce ballon va le
distraire ah non théodule net n'est plus
un enfant dont le ballon non mais ce qui
est à l'intérieur
enfin casimir pour sûr à l'intérieur il
n'y a rien enfin rien que de l'air oui
mais justement voilà regardez je vais
vous montrer vous lire le passage de la
lettre de mon cousin
il me dit je suis dans un pays où il ya
beaucoup de brouillard jeu tu as envie
de respirer le bon air de l'île aux
enfants ah je comprends la en casimir
ton cousin théodule des fora le neveu du
ballon et pour sûr
alors il respire a soudain le bonheur de
l'île aux enfants il fermera les yeux et
il verra il vit julie il verra les
enfants le verra latin leur poule il
verra le kiosque il verra la mer oui
mais il ya aussi dans le principal dont
vous n'avez pas parlé mais non on n'a
pas oublié casimir
la valeur dit long il verra
le moral est bon je lis ça va les unir
ne demande pas trop oh bien sûr que si
quand il n'est pas dans le jardin l'île
aux enfants n'est pas tout à fait la
même mais enfin aujourd'hui il est
absent juste pour la journée de toute
façon il était tellement content d'avoir
une aussi grande responsabilité c'est
frais c'est la première fois qu'il fait
quelque chose d'aussi en même temps ça
le le gardien du parc d'animaux étaient
vraiment gentil de lui confier la garde
des animaux pour la journée mais tu sais
qu'il est très content d'avoir trouvé
quelqu'un pour le remplacer aujourd'hui
que je suis sûr que casimir est un
excellent gardien tu as tout à fait
raison julie faut pas s'inquiéter les
animaux sont tellement heureux dans
l'île aux enfants casimir n'aura
pratiquement rien à faire on les enfants
volés bonjour julie est un salut
françois bon jour mais sa campagne aux
facteurs quel bon ben vous amène du
courrier pour moi ah non non non pas
aujourd'hui c'est même presque ce qu'on
pourrait appeler une visite à titre
privé je voulais être le premier à vous
annoncer la bonne nouvelle ça peste
raconter nice a vite poursuit on nous a
les actions pour les uns on ne nous fait
pas languir facteurs lesquels cette
grande nouvelle ben figurez vous que je
rencontre monsieur du snob nous
échangeons quelques mots quand tout à
coup je vois que ses yeux kikicé karting
alors je suis dans la direction de son
regard et devinez ce que je vois j'en ai
pas je donne ma langue au chat ah eh
bien je vois un énorme cargo qui entre
dans le port super majestueux et oui
c'était le casimir us premier qui
rentrait avec deux jours d'avancé mais
oui il est parti déjà il ya deux
semaines crée oui pour apporter
certaines espèces animales inconnu dans
l'île aux enfants oh mais on avait plein
surtout le pont j'ai vu d'elle et des
léopards des des ours blancs d'être des
perroquets
les animaux de toutes sortes ça devait
exploser
rouslan deal magnifique dit la vraie
fête
yaya revue tous les bateaux qui
actionnait la leur sirène
les gens sortaient de chez eux pour
aller sur le quai et les animaux à les
animaux les animaux étaient tous en
parfaite santé seulement certains
étaient c'est un peu fatigué le voyage
alors on les a tout de suite dirigés
vers le parc des animaux ou le gardien
doit être en train de s'en occuper bien
entendu mais françois le gardien
aujourd'hui c'est oui mais c'est quasi
me
mets pas du tout facteur le gardien du
parc d'animaux a justement choisi
aujourd'hui pour s'absenter il a confié
la garde des animaux a quasiment je me
demandais comment il va se débrouiller
mais à mon niveau j'ai besoin de vos
craintes il arrive un malheur
les émirs certains animaux se sont ils
tombés non mais il en est arrivé plein
de nouveau aujourd'hui web et ça nous
savons oui le facteur nous a mis au
courant mais moi mon problème c'est que
je ne sais pas ce qu'ils préfèrent un
show et ceux qui préfèrent le froid
casimir du connais leur espèce moi oui
j'ai toute une liste rares atouts d'audi
marque est oui bien que nous allons
demander aux enfants ils te donneront
sûrement les bonnes réponses je compte
sur vous et c'est une bonne idée
françois casimir remplace aujourd'hui le
gardien du parc d'animaux il ne tenait
pas les animaux qui préfèrent la chaleur
et les animaux qui préfèrent le froid
voulait bien l'aider c'est vrai oui
et vous serez casimir vient alors
casimir les enfants on commence un
phoque alors il aime le froid le chaud
quoi dans un pays froid j'm'en d'autres
sa saisine et vivant dans les pays
froids un sénèque
c'est un renard des sables fennecs sa
une le chaud le soleil le show le che
turin un chameau
un chameau le show et lyon
a lyon je souris chauves et lion est
mort ce
mort ce le froid une otarie
froid un tigre
le show un éléphant
chaud j'espère que chez eux nos seins
mais pas répondre avec vous un pingouin
le froid quelqu'un dit le show mais
c'est le froid un ours blanc le croire à
voir le froid rennes
non c'est pas les chaînes céline a
raison avesnes le froid
dans les pays froids le show un
crocodile
un crocodile de chaud par le froid
chercher chez vous une panthère il
survient sort vous êtes une panthère le
show un chien screamo
le froid est-ce que je vois les chaises
qui mot
dire les traîneaux dont il doit mettre
d'accord
me froid à zèbre
un zèbre le show non froid a guidé par
le show elle ou
non c'est le froid bahia certains loups
mais très très très très très peu qui
vivent dans les régions tempérées
mais la plupart des nous aiment le froid
un caribou
qu'est ce que c'est un très beau
le froid très bien un flamant rose
le show est bien casimir oui j'ai tout
passé en revue voilà tu sais tout et
bien tu vas en avoir du travail
pour sûr ce ne sera pas facile à faire
mais facteurs oui je voudrais vous
demander un petit service est ce que
vous ne pourriez pas me remplacer je ne
me sens pas très bien au jeu ça peut te
faire plaisir oui malades quasiment non
non je dis ce n'est pas très grave juste
un petit rhume avec toutes ces questions
je crois bien que j'ai attrapé un show
et l'effroi
vous aimez